I'm scared I'm super scared I'm scared
because I know exactly what happens this
month every year it's that time of year
again when college students turn their
castles and start a new chapter in their
lives I'm scared I'm scared because I
know that there are so many of you that
graduate this month and have no idea
what you want to do I'm starting on
there right because because I just and
that's okay
most people don't you should not be
stressed about that
I'm actually not scared about that
they're five seconds out I know you
don't but you don't think you can't not
know I just don't know right you've got
to get out of that rhythm yeah you got
to get into real-life rhythm yeah but
you're a kid you're a kid don't beat
yourself up if it's not coming easy yet
you have to decompose from that old
environment everybody's judging
themselves way too early what I would do
is gather as many experiences as
possible you know you're not lost in
life you're just early in the process
you know what I mean you're lost by
other people's standards not by your
actual if you actually took it
practically you're you haven't even
started to many people view post
university as like oh this is now real
and I'm lost they don't put it in the
context of being alive for a hundred
years and realizing they're only 20% of
the way done I'm scared that you don't
realize that you're entering the
greatest five year window of your life
if you are 22 years old and graduating
from college if you're 22 years old and
not graduating from college if you are
22 years old you are entering first of
all some of the greatest years of your
life
hey but be this this is the moment watch
this video twice if Mama's watching this
feminist senior daughter Sally right now
because you have to understand this next
five year window is when you don't go
practical and safe you've got a try
stuff the biggest reason you don't know
what you want to do is you haven't
tasted enough things and the biggest
reason you're not tasting enough things
is you're worried about finding it too
fast
how'd are you you can literally do
nothing for next eight years and be a
child but you don't think that because
when you're twenty - you don't think
thirty-one is young but it is this is
not the time to get the job mom wanted
you to this is not the time to try to
maximize as much money so you can buy a
loaf at WIPP you need to stop giving
about what anybody else has and realized
that if you put your head down and just
work for the next ten years no glamour
no new car suitcase jewelry tripped
event no Coachella no new sneakers like
the work you will have it and every time
you care about one of the things I just
mentioned and will slow down your
process of poverty you got your head up
that's right that's why it's interesting
you've got your head up and you're
trying to score at 22
just slowing you down and everybody else
dude you wrap your head around not
giving about any advancement to your 29
but then every day trying to get better
you went just close your eyes until
you're 29
the number-one reason I push patients is
because patients will give you the air
cover to take risk you've got plenty of
time to do it all and like yeah it's
gonna take a lot of hard work to do the
insanity you want but that's what I
would tell myself like that you will not
believe how young you will feel at 40
this is the time to realize that you
have a five-year window and it's three
for some it's eight brothers but there's
a five-year window for you to attack the
life that you want to win not because
it's the secret because the world shows
them cuz it's hardik there as a matter
of fact I'm probably more scared about
your naivete how hard class is easy
right what you've been doing for the
last 16 years is easy it's a game it's
structured it's easy the world this
thing this thing is hard however that
contradicts what I'm gonna tell you
right now which is this is the best and
easiest five years of your life because
this is one you need to attack what you
love and what you want to do here's why
you don't have all the baggage you may
have college loads respect it's harder
you may have the expectations of your
parents mentally hard fake hard parents
please like that win on their terms not
yours the children I'm not a direct
indication of who you are you may have a
lot of other things but this is exactly
when you can live with roommates in a
basement and fast food to this speech
because if you go for it as much as you
possibly go through it then if you
decide you gave it a good shot good
about it then if you started then
becoming practical it'd be far less
behind than you think
you understand this is not when the
baby's there some of your babies this is
not when you've been married and you
promised this is not when the world is
sucked out all your dreams and hopes yet
you should really go to a retirement
home one day and volunteer and just talk
to them it will make you one of you
every minute in your life because when
you see regret in a man's eyes it's
painful because you have a kid about it
when you're 90 and you're not mobile and
you're fired and it's over you can't do
it you can't do it you can't build that
company wanted you can't spend that time
with your kid you its regret and it
drives it it out of me you still got
this window and yet so many of you are
so hungry for short term short term
gains like maximizing the job that paid
you $3,000 more but it's not as fun but
you want that $3,000 for what
for what for a new iPhone your need of
things is killing you let me watch and
wit need to be happy you get to live
life one time and this is the time right
now to understand what's actually
happening and actually map your behavior
to something that will impact you for
the next 80 years so promise me promise
me all you youngsters that are watching
this right now in the comments cuz I'll
jump in and talk to you promise me that
you understand that the land grab of
happiness starts right now that you
don't have to worry about getting that
job what you should do is go and travel
and learn go and start that business
that you've always wanted
hook up with those three teammates and
start that band you've always wanted
this is the time to be massively risk
massively risk oriented because let me
tell you what's way more scary than
failure regret I'm so desperate to
figure out how to convince people that
there is no loss you told me for them
that yeah you might get made fun of and
you might have it in your own mind but
trying to figure out how to make people
just want that fear going in building a
business for themselves in 2012 trying
to figure out how to make a video or
give a talk or send it to me or write a
book just something that makes people
understand that executing the way it
always is following the school business
model just such a word is gonna lead you
to a place where you're not going to win
I know that this is when you're supposed
to grow up and go see the world but
guess what the world isn't what mommy
and daddy told you the world is exactly
going to be what it's going to be with
or without the way you thought it was
gonna be a ton is gonna change the world
changes every day
right now what you need to recognize is
you can afford to your biggest advantage
is your youth and too many and too many
kids don't take advantage of time so I
would take advantage of your youth and
and your flexibility at this kind of age
and try to taste everything play with
everything figure out what you might be
good at but you might like and then you
make a decision about it nobody else
defines you not me not everybody
watching that your mom - Ian's you data
you can grind and be patient for 10
years every day and still be nine years
young lady I would trade places with you
that's how amazing having time on your
side is this is what you put in the 18
hours a day to make your life that you
want happen I used to work in a liquor
store from 7:00 in the morning to 10:00
at night for seven straight years and
the only days off I took her to watch
the New York Jets and then globe cuz I'm
scared I can sear myself and talking I'm
not saying it's the secret its
practicality when you're in your early
20s this is when you can grind at your
highest levels because there isn't all
the baggage that comes across through
life it's harder for the 42 year olds
that are watching right now to listen to
this advice
you can't just wake up to her and be
like let's go cuz little Sally has
soccer practice and because you've got a
million other things that are holding
you down boy if you're lucky enough to
be graduating today with not idea of
what you're gonna do with your future
nobody's ever been luckier than you
please recognize
to many people view post University as
like oh this is now real and lost they
don't put it in the context of being
alive for a hundred years and realizing
they're only 20% of the way done almost
everything is perspective like I think I
think I'm just starting so imagine what
I think for most of you
[Music]
[Music]